hi welcome to another cold fusion for
you right now we're at the start of an
AI revolution
you might hear people talking about AI
threatening to take over jobs or doing
stranger things like playing games like
the board game go or Starcraft 2 but
most people think that the arts and
creative fields are outside AIS
capabilities but this is up for debate a
method called style transfer which
usually entails taking the artistic
style of a famous painter and
transferring it onto a still image or
even video has been achieved in the
instances of still images the AI managed
to fool 39% of art historians but what
about creative AI doing something
actually useful that could potentially
save millions of dollars and improve an
entire industry by leaps and bounds well
this is happening
a iess creativeness is now moving into
the 3d visual arts potentially
revolutionising video game production
and graphics in this video we'll take a
look at that and some other ways that
the AI revolution is seeping into gaming
you are watching ColdFusion TV
[Music]
since crisis from 2007 we haven't really
seen a major step forward in the visual
quality of games yes they do look
marginally better but it hasn't been an
incredible leap forward this is about to
change with something called a real-time
ray tracing ray tracing without going
into detail simulates the way light
reflects and interacts with surfaces in
the real world it does this by
calculating the past that each ray of
light would take in a scene ray tracing
gives their elements of realism that's
missing from today's games current games
fake the effect of life's behavior ray
tracing simulates it it's why Pixar
movies look so different to a playable
video game so this sounds good but the
problem with ray tracing is that it's
very computationally expensive
traditionally you need a big farm of
graphics processors to produce results
it's definitely something suited to
pre-rendered CGI movies and not
real-time video games this all changed
with NVIDIA Tsar TX graphics card with
this real-time ray tracing is now
possible this was achieved by
specialized Hardware tailored for AI
doing all of the heavy lifting the
hardware is called ng X and it uses
processes that are custom-built for
matrix multiplication the mathematical
heart and soul of modern AI with this
the hardware enabled AI learns how light
should bounce and simulates this it puts
the paths of light where it thinks that
should go the result is a realistic
real-time image that for the first time
comes down to the consumer level in 2019
ray tracing was integrated into Unreal
Engine and now the technology can be
used in very general cases to highlight
just how much of a difference ray
tracing makes here's a video by digital
foundry showing minecraft modded with
ray tracing
[Music]
minecraft is probably one of the worst
looking games graphics wise but with
ray-tracing
it actually looks pretty realistic it
doesn't end there though here's some
real-time ray tracing scenes of a BMW
juxtaposed with a shot of a real BMW
[Music]
[Applause]
and rounding up here some other general
examples of ray-tracing
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
in the future this kind of video game
quality will become standard
[Applause]
ai is also being used to create more
realistic smoke and fluid simulations
without the heavy processing that goes
with it not only this but a research
team at the university of edinburgh
developed a machine learning system that
is trained by watching motion capture
clips showing various kinds of movement
the system correspondingly then
generates an animation this can be
anything from a job to a run to hopping
over an object to train our system we
first cut through several long sequences
of raw locomotion data at a variety of
speeds facing directions and turning
angles we also capture motion of
stepping climbing and running over
obstacles placed in the capture studio
by giving us input the height of the
terrain under the trajectory our
character can adapt to rough terrain
climbing balancing and jumping we're
required either using the gamepad or the
environment we can get the character to
crouch or move under obstacles it can
additionally be forced into certain
environments such that the desired
motion is performed as shown walking
over this beam
[Music]
in summary we present a new method of
character control using a faes function
neural network which can produce
high-quality motion complex controlled
tasks such as walking over rough terrain
it's fast compact stable and can learn
from a large amount of data this takes
the tedious work out of creating
realistic movements of videogame
characters in a free market whatever is
cheaper faster and better will
eventually become the standard the same
applies to the gaming industry less
style of game development it's no secret
that the cost of video games is going up
but why is this
once upon a time major games could be
made with a small number of people this
is because the assets or 3d components
of the game was simple as time went on
games strove to chase realism as this
happened the components of the game
became ever more complex it's gotten to
the point where it now takes a large
team and the budget of a blockbuster
movie to complete a major video game
title Andrew price a video game artist
conducted a talk at a blender conference
in 2018 in the talk he produced a
realistic estimate of how exactly things
get so expensive so one detailed 3d
building can take 22 hours to create 12
hours for the modeling stage and another
10 hours for the texturing process but
the job is far from complete at this
stage there's usually a revision of two
to four times depending on what's needed
within the game's story the end process
can be 44 to 88 hours of work
just for a single building within a game
at a wage of $60 per hour the average
cost of one building is around $4,000
when you add up all the costs it becomes
comical this single scene cost around
$200,000 a full game would have no
problem reaching the hundreds of
millions of dollars mark working this
way the expense is largely due to the
process of designing the elements in the
game currently video game artists use a
static flow from the design of the
element to the output that is the
completed product is a one-to-one ratio
to create a new 3d asset be it a car or
building requires the designer to start
almost completely
scratch this is where AI comes in AI
particularly new your networks a suited
to a kind of workflow called procedural
content generation this is basically
where a neural network is trained to
create realistic buildings cars or audio
from vast volumes of data over time it
learns what looks good and what's
realistic with procedural content
generation a game designer simply has to
type in certain parameters such as a
building should be of a certain type
have X amount of windows and B of a
height within a certain range once given
these parameters the AI then generates a
whole bunch of options and the designer
simply has to pick one with little or no
modification and this is where the
advantage comes in if another 3d asset
is needed instead of starting from
scratch the designer simply puts in the
fur a meters and the AI generates it
again countless hours are saved even
though to train the AI in the first
place might take a while the same
process can be done for natural
landscapes or even video game characters
themselves to top things off what if an
AI could create a whole video game by
itself well of course this has already
been done just recently researchers at
Georgia Tech took things our step
forward by using a general adversarial
network a type of neural network which
we've covered extensively before on this
channel this network was deployed to
invent new games in their paper they use
video game levels from already developed
games as inputs and then converted them
into an output that lays out
environments objects and rules for the
new game this particular system learned
from two games Super Mario Brothers and
Kirby's Adventure and the output turned
out to be a game similar to Megaman
so I think this video shines a light on
a side of AI that isn't really talked
about AI being not only creative but
actually practically useful combining
all of the elements that you've seen
here it's clear to see that AI is going
to have a drastic effect on the future
of videogames they'll look better be
more realistic and be much cheaper to
produce
so which area are you most excited for
the possibility of the prices of games
coming down the games looking better or
the games being more realistic let me
know what you think in the comments
section below
so that rounds at the end of the video
my goal with all of this content on this
channel is to bring something a little
different to YouTube and you take on
presenting information if you want to
support this vision feel free to
subscribe to this channel and share this
video to someone who'll be interested in
the topic that really helps me out if
you're looking for more and want to be
surprised on the variety of things that
AI neural networks are capable of stick
around and I'll leave a link to my
neural network compilation video for you
to have a look at it's well worth for
watch oh yeah and don't forget to check
out my Instagram I've been more active
there recently anyway thanks for
watching this has been - go go you've
been watching cold fusion and I'll see
you again soon for the next video cheers
guys have a good one
[Music]
are you thinking
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]